-Hey guys, it's time
for our latest installment
of "Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
♪ "Polls" ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-This first poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a good one.
[ Cheering ]
-This next poll asked...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Uh, it's called a life hack.
Google it.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Scat sings
"The Price Is Right" theme ]
-It's called a --
It's called a life hack.
Google it.
[ Laughter ]
This next one asks...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No way! No!
Double whammy!
-Little brain gymnastics.
[ Cheering ]
Next one asks...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's an app.
-App.
-Appetizer.
-That's an appetizer.
Nice.
-This next poll asks...
-Wow!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This next poll asks...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
That was a good answer.
Last poll asks...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it, those are
your "Tonight Show Polls."